Hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is gonna be my flash
episode 11 video the Sound and the Fury
so we got meet Pied Piper
Hartley Rathaway, so I'm going to do an
explainer for his character
like a character history from the
comics and then I'll talk about some of
the reverse Flash stuff that we learned
lots of new details so we still have like
a ton of episodes left this season so
I think it's a little too soon to guess
exactly what's going on but we did get
some cool clues
and some really awesome easter eggs that
I'll explain okay so just careful for
spoilers from the episode just cuz I'll
be referencing this weeks episode as
well as some moments from last week's
episode
Hartley Rathaway is the son of the
two characters that we saw last week the
ones that had the painting that the
rogues were trying to steal
as Harrison Wells explained they
ostracized him for being gay
which totally sucks so instead of
joining the family business he joined
star labs and became a physicist because
he's a genius
on the level of Harrison Wells well
Harrison Wells is kind of hiding
a lot of things so
maybe he's not quite as smart as Harrison Wells. That was one of the really big
things about them bring the character on
the show, they wanted a character
that they would have to defeat on
intellectual level they didn't want
someone that the flash could just outrun
or outspend. That's one of the problems with superheroes having friends with
unlimited funds
it's like if you need a really cool piece of
technology you can just fabricate it
no problems money is an issue so they
wanted to bring a rogue on
that would challenge them on a different
level the funny thing is that
the show runners describe the character
as thinking of himself as something of an
evil Harry Potter
which gives new meaning to the chess
game it reminded me of the
Harry Potter chess game that the big
real life chess game at the end that
first movie
he kinda does look like he's cos
playing Harry Potter little bit with
those robes on
so in the comics it's actually his first
appearance was the same
first appearance as Gorilla Grodd so he
and Gorilla Grodd debuted at the same time
it was that Flash number 106 Menace of the Super gorilla
slash the Pied Piper of Peril and the
interesting thing about that story is
Piped piper helped
the flash, helped Barry Allen defeat
Gorilla Grodd
so he has worked with the flash in the
past he's not like a completely evil
character like some the flash villains
he is one of the first DC characters to
come out as gay, he's actually captain
Sing's boyfriend
in the in the flash comics they haven't fully
explained it other although captain sing
has mentioned his boyfriend
it is interesting to know that one of
the Rogues is dating the captain of the
police department it is just a funny
thought like oh here's my boyfriend
super criminal as the show explained he has a really strained relationship
with his parents
in the comics actually they were
murdered and he was framed for it
he was even hypnotized to believe that he had done it eventually he got cleared
and they found out that it was the Evan
McCollough Mirrormaster that had done it
on blacksmiths orders so he and mirrormaster have this really big feud so
if mirrormaster ever comes on the show
I'll be interested to see if they play
it that way
ok so here we go getting into top five
moments now so number five
Harrison Wells running around without
the reverse flash suit on
so I had to explain I saw a lot of people
commenting on Twitter they were
a little confused by the red lightning
a lot of people were thinking that he
might be a future version a Barrly Allen
because  of the red streak
just explain what's going the speed force
whenever the flash is running
he gives off yellow lightning the reverse flash is the one that gives off
red lightning so regardless of who Harrison Wells really is which version
of the reverse he is
he's not the same person as Barry Allen
but it's just a lot of fun as we get
deeper into the season we start learning
more and more about him
as we start seeing him act more as the
reverse flash
number four the prodigal son returns meet
Hartley Rathaway
I really like the crazy relationship
that we saw on the flashbacks between
Harrison wells
and Hartley both them are very
abrasive people like they're both
kind of assholes
but they have this camaraderie this
Brotherhood of minds of all the things in
the episode that I feel like they could've
done a little bit better
it would've been explaining what
Hartley's purpose was at Star labs
Harrison wells had that explainer is
like oh you know his parents
hate him because he's gay he was my
number one guy it doesn't really do justice to
to the pathos that his character has in the
past
obviously we know why he so pissed off
in present-day because of what Harrison Wells
did to him
the really interesting thing is that he
is the second flash villain
or the next in the line rouges that has
goaded
the flash into a fight on false pretense
so, remember in the last episode
the rogues already had the painting this
started the fight with the flash
with the sole purpose of taking him down
Piped Piper
did the exact same thing so he committed
a crime got the flash to take him in so
that he could get the stuff that he needed
to kill the flash in a later encounter
he is just the next in a long line of people
to pull a fast one
on the flash you make as many jokes
about that as you want
it does a really good job of playing into this
theme of your heroes letting you down
you letting your heroes down
broken trust is going to be a lot of
that going around later this season
moving on to number three: Joe and Eddy
are investigating Harrison Wells
behing Barry's back
they just got done with that moment
where Barry was telling
Joe that is he still his number one guy no one's gonna come between like the same
conversation
that Harrison wells had with Hartley Rathaway which is kinda funny
it's all about trust and hero worship and
then right away
Eddy walks in and says you really want to
do this you really want investigate
Harrison
and Joe is like hell yeah I do, clearly barry
is going to be
very disappointed in Joe at some point
just like he is going to be disappointed in
Harrison
when he finds out what's really going on
like his real reverse flash plan
when you think about it, it seems like
everyone's going to end up hating each
other at the end of the season
everybody has something about themselves
that they're not telling someone else
moving on to number two Cisco versus Piped Piper
it's so fun to see Cisco finally get a
rivalry like he has a nemesis now
he seems like such a positive person
it's hard to believe that there's
someone that he does not like
they teased a upcoming firestorm episode
at the end when Hartley Rathaway's like
I know all about firestorm you're gonna
let me out because I'm gonna help you
find him
that's another situation like you have
with the flash and the reverse flash
of Harrison and Barry Allen as well as
the rogues captain cold and heatwave
there's always like a pair of characters
one of them creates an elaborate plan
they need the other person to help them
and then they may not like them quite as
much they might have to put up with them
so like captain cold not a huge fan of
heatwave but
really need his help in taking down the
flash then you have the reverse flash
or Harrison wells who wants to siphon the
Speed Force for some
elaborate plan can't really tell if he likes
the flash at least he is tolerating
the flash because he needs him
and now you have Cisco and Hartley Rathaway so Cisco is going to be forced to
work with someone he doesn't like
because he wants to find his friend I
really like the way they're structuring the
narrative that way
where you have these elaborate plans
that each of the characters are
involved in
and they always need someone else to
complete it and the story of their
relationship with that other person
becomes really interesting and my number
one moment Harrison Wells
explains his plan so that wasn't totally
clear
obviously he's using the tachion
device to siphon speed force
it seems like he's going to take Barry
Allen's milkshake
and drink it up
like that's what his ultimate plan
is the temporary fix being the
tachion device
the real question is what does he
want to do with speed force once he gets it
i think is going to try and alter the
timeline his relationship with the speed force
also raises a lot of questions
what i think is going on is they're mixing
and matching details
from different versions of the reverse
flashed so Harrison Well's character draws
from
aspects from Eobard Thawne as well as Hunter Zolomon
so he is not one or the other the show's is
just like mixing and matching
aspect so its faithful to the comics but
not in the literal sense like it's not
copy and paste
if you're not familiar with the story of Eobard Thawne so he's from the 25th
century
in that era the Speed Force does not
exist there are no flashes
they do have a flash museum where they
study the Speed Force
Eobard becomes an expert in flash
studies he really idolizes Barry Allen
there was a lot of talk about people
idolizing people in this episode so the
students at the school there at the
flash museum name him
professor zoom because he's so smart
because he knows so much about the flash
eventually he comes into possession of
the flashes suit
uses that to replicate the experiment
the created the Barry Allen flash
and then becomes the Reverse Flash but
he can't become the Reverse Flash
if Barry Allen never became the flash
right now he seems more like a battery
operating at half charged like he keeps
having to recharge himself
every once in a while, that also seems
like a narrative device because if his
powers worked the same way barry allen's did then why wouldn't he just super
speed all over the place
all the time if you've never read it, the
story that immediately precedes
flashpoint deals with the idea the
multiverse
and how Barry Allen is the generator of
the Speed Force
so like all the other flashes all over
the multiverse
all originate from Barry Allen he's the
person that creates the speed force
or so to speak
that all them all live off so if he dies
the speed force dies with him
which is why it's so important he stays
alive Tom Cavanagh also at the TCA's
described himself as a
time-traveling thief so I think if
you gonna call him one flash or the other
I'm gonna call him Eobard Thawne but I
don't think that's exactly the way his
character's gonna play out
feel free to leave all your theories in
the comments though we all have
great Reverse flash theories
we're going to get a whole lot more
Harrison Wells running around doing
crazy stuff
so here is my big question for you guys do
you think that Hairston wells
is a combination of
multiple reverse flashes his character
is from the comics in
what do you think he's gonna do once he
gets Barry Allen's powers once he takes
his speed force
so while you guys think about that here are just
some of the easter eggs i saw on the episode
so we had Royal Flush gang at the
beginning they were also featured on
arrow to so they're they're kind of like
being passed around the DC TV universe
believing in heroes, heroes believing us was a
common theme across the entire episode
so if you never read Eobard Thawne idolized
the Barry Allen flash before he became
the reverse flash
so you have Barry worshiping the person
who worshipped him
as a child, it's really funny Harrison
Wells talked about the road from the
earth to the stars
I'd like to believe that's a subtle easter
egg for the new gods Geoff Johns is
getting ready to write like a Ryan
comic like a new gods comic real soon
maybe season 2 we might see some more
easter eggs for new gods but
they're a little more fantastical so I'm not
expecting them on the show
anytime soon
Then Piped Piper starts talking about
vibrational frequency everything has a
vibrational frequency
so the flash is able to actually vibrate his molecules
through solid objects so we'll see him face
through walls hopefully before the end
of the season
also the universe has a vibrational
frequency so
he can vibrate into other dimensions
under the right circumstances
that would be like the back door to
flash in two world so you hopefully we'll
get to that
in like you know maybe the next two or
three seasons no idea when they will get into
multiverse
if you saw any other easter eggs that I did not
mention somewhere in the video just
write them below on the comments
but I think the only big thumbs down I
had were one you know Hartley's
character
didn't feel like you know it was quite
shown why he was such a dick in the past
Harrison Wells explained it but TV is very much like a show me
not tell me medium so i feel like the
explanation didn't really do him justice
and i mentioned it before but this is like
the second big rogue to go the flash into
a fight
so at some point they're gonna
have to acknowledge it like okay Barry fight
smarter not
fight faster this is all a process
though I mean this is the story of
the flash
becoming the flash getting better you
know you expect him to fall in his face
every once in a while
so next week really awesome stuff we're
going to get to see some really flash
karaoke be sure to subscribe to that
video
we'll get to see Barry Allen have a real
deal sex life for those asking
my agents of shield video is gonna post
tomorrow morning and if you haven't seen
already I just did a trailer breakdown
for Fantastic Four so a whole lot of superhero
stuff happening tonight
it's been a really interesting day so if
you guys haven't seen it yet I did a big
explainer video for Gorilla Grodd
and his characteristics in the comics they basically
teased he is gonna be coming back in
season one
you can click here to learn all about
its gonna be really cool and you can
click here
if you haven't seen the Fantastic Four
trailer thank you so much for watching
so let's all high five I'll see you
guys tomorrow